so let's hold that as the highest
probability outcome yeah let's switch to
what the hell do people do if you're
alright
right if that actually occurs well at
what level are we talking now
are we talking personally investment or
what so let's focus on the investment
side we could the personal side there's
plenty of information out there but from
the investment seat what do people do in
terms of one preparing for this and then
two if it actually occurs how do they
act or think through the various
opportunities that present them
let's ignore profiting from it for now
we come back to trading it that's a
different thing the average person
there's gonna be a lot of job losses
just because companies will not be able
to fort it there's government's gonna
have to try and support companies
they're doing that in China there is
going to be so you've got a significant
chance of job losses that's the main
thing you have a significant chance of
meddling medical expenses in the United
States which is a big problem of the
system here so it is an economic event
for most households and a significant
economic event are you ready for that
and that means and one of the best piece
of advice I was ever given was given
back to me in 1991 which was he who has
cash in a recession is king I like to
say he who has cash makes the rules Yeah
right but the point being is whatever
you do just have some cash at hand this
is not a financial event where we have
to worry about the bank's sure it might
morph into something and I'm not making
predictions on that but just to have
some cash because just make sure you've
got the availability to deal with this
and maybe I'm wrong what have you lost
nothing but what are you what are you
you're more prepared so that's and you
know and I've been and it won't be many
of the viewers or listeners to this but
if you are approaching retirement I've
again at real vision we've done this
screamed and shouted about the
allocation people have in their pensions
they are taking too much risk hoping to
breach that magic number well if I am
right then
the downside is enormous and it won't
recover for a significant period of time
over which period people are going to
get laid off or retired so in which case
they don't get to buy the dip so you
have too much equity you have too much
credit and you've never earned enough
bonds because you've always thought bond
yields of 1% aren't worth it well this
is why you learned that bonds are the
greatest thing on earth so you've been
long bonds yeah
obviously done very well there yeah
we've seen Treasury yields go to very
low levels walk us through kind of your
current view of the bonds and in light
of the Treasury yield movement yes I
have been hoping for a sharp pull back
there'll be a point where you get this
gut check that usually happens in the
middle of these and again this is from
experience of trading these you get a
movement against today because the
central bank's announce something and
everyone thinks it's going to be safe
you have to look through that and say
well what are the central bank's going
to do to this situation nothing there's
nothing they can do all they're doing is
showing the receipts of the recovery in
due course that's what central banks do
and so any opportunity to buy bonds you
buy bonds because rates are going to
zero everywhere and they're probably
going negative
now everyone goes negative bonds never
gonna happen you tell me that when I
stock markets down 50% and all the other
assets are falling and the credit
markets blowing up I'll pay two percent
all day to have my money back people
don't understand the value of getting
your money back versus the interest rate
and it's the value of getting your money
back that's so important so I think
bonds will go negative and they're
negative all around the world and have
been for years now and that hasn't blown
up it's a it's a death of the banking
system over time but it's not instant
nuke button is it fair to say that you
look at bonds in this kind of depression
Airy type environment if that occurs as
the best opportunity was part of the
worst opportunities but they're a call
option because right the Fed aren't
gonna raise rates so bonds aren't gonna
move against you if think you're in
price terms if all hell breaks loose
you'll get your money back in bonds but
if all hell breaks loose and the bond
price rallies which it will do you'll
make a [ __ ] ton so it's basically looks
like a call option in environment like
this this is why people might stand
Druckenmiller
makes all his money from euro dollars
and bonds because if they have such
skewed risk/reward
also equities move around
around human behavior there's no
anchoring to equities you know that's
why valuations go up and down Eurodollar
futures are anchored by the interest
rate yeah they can move a little bit
away from where the Fed Funds rate is
whatever so basically they have to
reflect economic truths one way or the
other that can get better the head of
the truth or behind they can get it
wrong get it right but generally over
time they have to follow what the where
the interest rates are the long bond is
basically that plus future inflation
that's it so you have a clean macro
variable to aim for so if you're just
forecasting where rates are going you
can trade euro dollars if I say rates
are going to zero what you should be
saying is Ralph thinks euro dollars
going to a hundred and therefore they're
currently try to get 98 99 40 therefore
there's not a 60 ticks upside therefore
can i buy the calls with it you know
that's how everybody thinks when you
think of euro dollars and I've spent the
best part of year trying to educate
people about bonds because the narrative
driven by the investment industry is
bonds bad equities good and it's wrong
because and and
when you look at in price appreciation
terms bonds are pretty much helpful
equities over the long run for a very
long time here because in price
appreciation terms they're so phenomenal
but the little trick the little hoodwink
from the asset managers firms is a look
at the yield well that's like just
saying equities dividend yield no it's
the price and the price appreciation on
bonds has been truly extraordinary as
this massive demographic wave of people
the baby booms has come through and
dampened inflation and dampen growth
things the bond yields a bombs have
exploded and bond yields are forward you
think that I'll continue yes got it how
do you think about like that bond bond
position that you have taking profits
doubling up just kinda wrestling you're
correct yes doubled up and went kind of
max limit long and that's also the
advice that I gave to global macro
investor which is there have kind of
home research service and also in the
kind of rubbage and pro stuff so I just
said listen this is the time to take the
maximum risk because I know the
narrative or know where it's going up
seen this before everyone's going to
panic be ahead of the panic and make
money for it so now we're in the middle
of that where the narrative is caught up
with the reality right you didn't shake
my hand when we walk in right so that's
narrative reality me now cuz I don't
like you just you know no but I read
from the CDC I must was a chef I've got
my hand sanitizer right so so that is
the narrative catching up with with
weather markets are so the mock we've
got the cut which is what the bum mark
it was after as well the bond markets
telling us we're gonna get another cut
at the Fed meeting so the Fed will go a
hundred then I love it on Twitter now
because you can see where the narrative
is that out of is oh my god the Fed
they're idiots they're cutting wise
how's this gonna help what they're not
understanding is what the forward
narrative is the forward narrative is
this is not recession this is a
potential depression you have to do
anything you can do to stop that
happening and secondly if you understand
that the u.s. is about to start testing
for Coronas virus in larger numbers over
the next four weeks we're going to go
from whatever we are today 100 and some
in cases or turn our cases and we're
gonna go to 2,000
and we're gonna go to 10,000 mm-hmm at
an unbelievable rate and in an election
year
you are incentivized to panic as a state
local authority government everybody
sitting like war right is an anytime
that you can be the one in charge in a
time of chaos panic uncertainty etc
there's a higher likelihood that you
will stay in office because the
transition scares people right yes
although I do think that Trump made and
it's too early win the election but to
understand what's going on we don't even
know whether it's gonna be buying us
arms or whatever but Trump made a very
bad error by the political era was was
you know getting rid of half the CDC
okay fine whatever that's politics when
he had to stand up in front of the
nation and say we've got a problem like
Boris Johnson just did and I don't like
Boris Johnson but I was pretty impressed
with him saying what he said except for
he said he went to the hospital took
everyone's hand he's fine because he's
an idiot but good but you know he's
maybe for saying it as well yes you know
because if that was the moment people
did with HIV it's like this is not the
same as HIV this spreads by hand yeah
and so Trump didn't say anything a pop
I'm gonna put Mike Pence a look at it
it's not really important he they spread
the fruit flu narrative that still won't
die down and that was irresponsible
because if we find out that in six weeks
time we've got 50,000 cases
then all hell is gonna break loose and
because of the freedom of travel that's
still going on in the United States it
is not not small probability